[Music]
s p 500 nasdaq etfs if you listen to the
news these are terms you've heard many
times
but if you're like many of us you might
have no clue what they mean
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream in
this episode of perspectives three
financial experts give an easy to
understand history of the stock market
and share a range of investing concepts
that will help shed light on this
confusing world of financial acronyms
we begin now in 1792 with the birth of
the new york stock exchange enjoy
[Music]
the genesis of the new york stock
exchange was way back on may 17 1792
when 24 stock brokers got together under
the now famous buttonwood tree in front
of 68 wall street
all 24 signed what became known as the
buttonwood agreement
they set the rules for buying and
selling the stocks and the bonds that
are fundamental to the financial
industry
today we enjoy the benefits of efficient
low-cost securities markets
our ancestors didn't have it so good
trading stocks was expensive and slow
communication was more difficult record
keeping was done by hand and lots of
paper had to be mailed back and forth
investing wasn't typically thought of as
a respectable profession
it was viewed more like astrology or a
game of chance
run by crooks and people with inside
information
and using inside information was legal
at the time
before congress created the securities
and exchange commission in 1934
to regulate the financial markets after
the great depression
it was optional for firms to produce
audited financial statements on a
regular basis
it's even been said that joe kennedy
john f kennedy's father
was appointed as the first chairman of
the sec
because he knew many of the tricks the
scammers used to stack the deck in their
favor
many investors at the time traded on
rumors or hot tips
joe kennedy once said he knew it was
time to get out of the market when he
received stock tips from a shoeshine boy
other investors use an early form of
technical analysis
making investment decisions based on
stock price and volume changes
back then there were no computers
but there were stock ticker machines
that produce quotes on thin strips of
paper
maybe you've seen photographs of a
ticker tape parade after the world
series
or perhaps you were a fan of the 1960s
tv show the addams family
gomez adams who played the debonair
father in a ghoulish household was often
excited to read the ticker tape coming
out of his home stock ticker machine
before the days of bloomberg terminals
and yahoo finance charts
the ticker tape listed all the
information that many investors had with
which to make an investment decision
and that was the stock symbol
price change in price and volume of
shares traded
that's it
from that modest beginning under the
buttonwood tree stock markets have
undergone an explosion in their
influence on our economy
the financial services sector comprised
just 2.8 percent of the united states
gross domestic product in 1950.
in 2006 just before the financial crash
of 2007 it had grown to
8.3 percent
growth in trading volume is even more
dramatic
according to the world federation of
exchanges the dollar volume of stocks
traded on the new york stock exchange
now often called the nicey about doubled
from 1997 to 2000 then followed up by
tripling from 2000 to 2008.
from 2001 when shanghai first made the
list at just under 300 billion until
2008 shanghai's trading volume jumped
nine times its 2001 volume to 2.6
trillion
from 1929 to 2009 the total trading
volume of stocks in the dow jones
industrial average doubled about every
seven or eight years and starting early
in the 21st century it began doubling
about every three years
all of that increase in trading volume
hasn't been uniform across the world
in 1990 the new york stock exchange
headed the list of stock exchanges
ranked by trading volume the tokyo
exchange was second while the london and
frankfurt
exchanges ranked third and fourth
the national association of securities
dealer's automated quotation system or
nasdaq which is essentially a
computerized trading system was less
than 20 years old and ranked fifth
shanghai wasn't even on the list of the
big exchanges in 1990.
by the year 2000 though the advantages
of the nasdaq system had rocketed it to
the top of the list of trading venues
and by 2010 shanghai was beginning to
flex its muscles as a world financial
center mostly at the expense of european
exchanges in tokyo
those exchanges were still growing in
trading volume just not fast enough to
keep up with shanghai and the nasdaq
system
for now new york the home of both the
new york stock exchange and the nasdaq
system
remains the financial center of the
world at least as measured by stock
trading volume
shanghai is making a big splash though
and given the rapid development of
financial markets in china that's likely
to continue europe and tokyo show some
growth in volume but not enough to hold
their relative positions on this list of
six major exchanges
these stock markets are interrelated
some stocks list on more than one
exchange
daimler ag the parent of mercedes-benz
listed on both the frankfurt and new
york stock exchanges for many years
generally investors find it easier to
trade on an exchange in their home
country
the world federation of exchanges says
the trading volume on the new york stock
exchange and its related exchanges
totaled over 33.5
trillion dollars in 2008.
some people are wondering what companies
can possibly do with all that money
the answer is that they aren't getting
that money
almost all of that trading volume is in
what's called the secondary market the
secondary market is like the used car
market
if i sell my car to you
then you pay me the manufacturer nissan
or ford doesn't get anything
why should they it's my car not theirs
it's the same thing with stocks if i
sell you my ford shares then you pay me
not ford
ford just changes its records to record
you as the new owner
almost all of that trading volume
results in money moving from the pocket
of one investor to another the company
that issued the stock doesn't raise any
new funds at all
the primary market is different
if ford or nissan wants to raise money
then it can have a seasoned equity
offering or an seo
in an seo a company sells new shares and
that increases the number of shares
already held by investors
in that case ford does get the proceeds
of the sale of the new shares
when you buy an individual stock
can you lose all your money
the answer is yes
history is filled with stories of many
companies that did not make it
so
how can you invest in stocks without
taking on a level 5 risk
well you can invest in a wide selection
of stocks rather than betting on one
company
you do this by buying mutual funds or
exchange traded funds and specifically a
type of fund called an index fund
index funds are baskets of stocks
designed to replicate the aggregate
performance of an entire category of
companies
the s p 500 index offers one example
this is a measure of the collective
performance of 500 of the largest u.s
based publicly traded companies
you might invest in a mutual fund as
part of your retirement plan
or through a 401k or ira or part of your
basic savings
a mutual fund such as magellan offers
the same portfolio of investments for
all of its shareholders
so if you put in ten thousand dollars
and i put in five thousand you'll have
twice as many shares as me but will both
own the same investments with the same
returns
we each own pro-rata portions of the
fund
now that said sometimes the funds have
different share classes
large investors or institutions usually
belong to a class of shares paying lower
fees than small investors do
these fees may include management fees
marketing fees and administration fees
some funds also come with a sales charge
called a load that's paid to the seller
of the fund
no load funds avoid the sales charge and
generally have better net performance
even though the pre-fee returns of load
and no load funds tend to be similar
if the fees sound confusing to you
you're not alone
the expense ratio is the all-in number
that expresses the fees you pay on a
percentage basis
that is as a percentage of your overall
investment
actively managed stock funds have an
expense ratio on average of about one
percent
actively managed bond funds have an
average expense ratio of 0.5 percent or
50 basis points
you might be asking what's a basis point
well
100 basis points equals one percent
it sounds like a little but it can add
up as a cost
index funds are a lot cheaper
an index fund is a mutual investment
with a portfolio selected to match the
components of a market index such as the
s p 500
they usually have an expense ratio of
0.2 percent or 20 basis points or even
less
now most mutual funds trade only once a
day at 4 pm after the market closes
even though the basket of assets they
own like shares and ford motor trade all
day long
by way of contrast an investment that
looks something like a mutual fund
called an exchange traded fund or etf
trades throughout the day
that is price changes continuously to
reflect the updated value of its
underlying assets
and this intraday trading feature is one
reason why they the etfs have become
increasingly popular in recent years a
good part of asset allocation is
diversification
true
you can diversify your portfolio of
stocks and eliminate as much as 70
percent of the risk you'd take if you
held just one stock
still that leaves 30 percent of the risk
the market risk that you can't eliminate
if you hold stocks then you'll hold
market risk
that's one reason my why you might want
to hold some bonds
they tend to be safer than stocks and
their value doesn't move in lockstep
with the market
a bond is a loan
here's how it works
if i were starting widget corporation
suppose i ask you to lend me
let's say ten thousand dollars for ten
years
i agree to pay you four percent a year
the ten thousand dollars is your
principal
the four percent is called the coupon
rate and i send you four hundred dollars
each year
at the end of the ten years assuming i'm
a viable company and still in business
you get your ten thousand dollars back
you know exactly what income you'll get
and when you'll get your principal back
but what happens if you want to sell
your bond before the 10 years is up
well you go to market and what you get
for your bond will depend on where
interest rates are
suppose you've owned your bond for five
years
the market looks at your bond paying
four percent with five years left to
maturity
and compares it to other bonds that also
have five years to maturity
if interest rates have gone up
and new five-year bonds are paying six
percent well yours is paying four
percent
then the market will probably not value
your bond at its full face value of ten
thousand dollars
you might get about nine thousand two
hundred dollars for it
professional bond traders try to take
advantage of potential changes in market
sentiments and interest rates by trading
in and out of bonds
most of us are not professional bond
traders
so
for the average person there are two
ways to incorporate bonds into your
retirement portfolio
you can either invest in bonds through
mutual funds that specialize in bonds
and contain a large basket of them
or you can purchase individual bonds
directly through a broker
a lot of what you know from other
markets like groceries and car
dealerships is true for stock markets
too
you face a trade-off between risk and
inspected return
what is your personal risk tolerance
everyone needs a strategy to deal with
risk
and one aspect of a risk management plan
is to identify how much you want to earn
for retirement for instance
or
how much can you afford to lose
and what are your upper and lower
boundaries in terms of financial risk
and reward
when you're starting out in life
typically you can afford to take on
greater financial risks
even with fewer assets
on the expectation that your nest egg
even if it's small
will grow
and you'll have time to overcome any
losses
you'll then want to find a level of
diversification
consistent with your risk tolerance
owning a portfolio of treasury
securities is not very diversified
but it is considered low risk
owning a portfolio of distressed assets
is also not very diversified and the
risk might be quite high
but
if you combine
lower and higher risk instruments like
growth stocks utility bonds and other
instruments
you can develop a custom blended
portfolio for your personal risk
tolerance
the next question is
do i want to take an active investing
approach to my portfolio or a passive
investing approach active investing is
where you are trying to pick the best
stocks or best trading strategy
if you buy an actively managed mutual
fund the fees are higher they must
employ additional research analysts and
trade more and that adds to costs
contrast that with an index fund which
is a passive strategy
the index fund owns all the stocks that
fall into a specific category and
doesn't try to trade in and out of them
when you compare the results of actively
managed funds with passive or index
funds
research has shown that over long
periods of time after fees you are
almost always better off using passive
strategies that do not try to time the
markets and that do not try to do stock
picking
on another point if you are hiring a
professional advisor find out what
approach he or she uses if it's an
active trading strategy be aware that it
may cost more and not deliver superior
results
also be aware that there is a
distinction between paying for active
management versus paying an advisor to
set up an investment plan and manage
that plan for you
three things will continue to determine
how much you have at the end of your
investment
how much you invest your rate of return
and how long you invest
minimizing taxes and transactions costs
are the easiest way to increase your
rate of return
these principles will keep you grounded
as you decide whether or not to buy
stocks
[Music]
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
on one dream and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel for
new episodes of perspectives and you can
watch previous ones here